the banks the major corporations people
who should have been on the line for
what they did to the economy and almost
completely destroying the world economy
ended up discovering that a much easier
way and a cheaper way to improve their
image after 2008 was to go very very big
on all the identity politics stuff you
know Coots bank for instance just a
single one out the Queen's bank is now
covered in Pride flags at the front of
the of the office and say a safe
environment for all of our come on Coots
has had gays working there for years
it's not been a problem but they go big
on it they go big on it after the the
victories have been won you know I'm
afraid that you know the American
Military wasn't great on gay rights up
until yesterday they weren't great on
gay rights when I was growing up when
you couldn't be in the American Military
and be openly gay so they all jump onto
the bandwagon after it's actually
effectively finished